pregunta los puntos de la siguiente
gráfica representan una función bueno
vamos a hacer un pequeño recordatorio de
que era una función una función es una
cosa que usualmente denotamos por efe
esta es la letra más común que a cada
valor a cada valor en x le asigna un
valor en otra forma de pensar esta
función efe es que tenemos una caja aquí
tenemos una caja que se llama la función
f a la cual podemos meterle un valor en
x y nos da un valor en un valor en un
único valor en g
entonces la función sabe exactamente qué
hacer cuando le metemos un valor x que
sería una cosa que no es una función
pues bueno si la función duda entre
elegir ye o elegir digamos un cierto
valor w o elegir un valor
un valor y entonces esto de aquí no
sería una función vale no sería una
función porque si le metemos un valor
ésta efe esta caja no sabe si mandarnos
a w
o no sabe a cuál elemento del rango
tenemos que caer muy bien entonces con
esto en mente vamos a ver si estos
puntos que están aquí en el plano nos
determinan una función y cómo le hacemos
pues básicamente estos puntos lo que nos
dicen por ejemplo este 2 este punto de
acá lo que nos dice es que al 2 le toca
el menos 2 entonces vamos a leer la
información de cada uno de estos puntos
a ver si podemos determinar si estos
puntos representan o no una función vale
déjame empezar con este punto que voy a
poner así en color amarillo este de acá
entonces ese punto ese punto es el punto
menos 1,3 es el punto menos 13 lo voy a
poner así menos 13 otra forma de
escribir menos 13 es con esta caja
verdad voy a ponerlo así mira que el
menos uno menos uno
tenemos a la función a la función y a
cambio obtenemos el valor 3 entonces
hasta aquí todo va bien el menos 1
sabemos exactamente dónde cae déjame
pasar al color naranja para tomar este
punto de acá que es el 2 menos 2 sus
coordenadas son dos menos 2 lo voy a
poner aquí 2 - 2 y por lo tanto nos dice
que el 2 lo metemos a la cajita hasta la
cajita y a cambio obtenemos el menos 2
todo va muy bien verdad un valor entra y
obtenemos un único valor vamos a este
punto de por acá este punto de por acá
es el 3 el 3,23 2 entonces el 3 está
entrando en esta caja
y a cambio obtenemos un 212 entonces
todo va súper bien parece ser que estos
puntos de esta cosa que representan
estos puntos si quiere ser una función
hasta ahorita todo va excelente pero
cuando llegamos al 4 parece ser que hay
problemas y en realidad esta cosa que
quería hacer una función no va a poder
serlo déjame decirte porque aquí en el 4
aquí en el 4 tenemos la el punto de
coordenadas
4 - 1 y también tenemos el punto de
coordenadas 4,5
voy a ponerle aquí 4 - 1 y 4,5 y
entonces qué sucede si lo pensamos como
la cajita el 4 lo metemos a la caja
efe pero no obtenemos un único valor no
sabemos si obtenemos -1 o si obtenemos 5
entonces esta caja bueno le habíamos
llamado función pero en realidad no es
función era función hasta antes del 4
pero al llegar al 4 la función o más
bien esta relación se conoce como
relación cuando cuando no es función de
esta relación no sabe qué hacer con el 4
no sabe si mandarlo al menos uno o si
mandarlo al 5 y por lo tanto no puede
ser función vale y hay otro criterio
visual que ayuda a determinar que algo
no es una función y se llama el criterio
de la línea vertical a qué se refiere
este criterio pues por ejemplo aquí en
el 4 podemos trazar una línea vertical
y observamos que pasamos por dos puntos
por éste y por este el hecho de pasar
por dos puntos nos estás diciendo que al
4 le estamos asignando 2 valores en que
la relación tiene contemplados dos
valores en ye para el 4 y por lo tanto
hay ambigüedad entre cuál de ellos le
asignaría en caso de ser una función de
esta forma ya trazamos una línea
vertical y pasamos por dos o más puntos
entonces la relación no puede ser una
función vale bueno entonces estará
carlos función porque le asigna dos
valores al 4